steve want your old collider
you can stick that up i'm pretty sure um
okay uh how are you doing today sir good
night oh yeah i'm doing excellent um
like everyone walking in the room before
me uh
i'm sure they're saying the same thing
i'm about to say the movie is incredible
one of my favorites of the year uh i
can't believe what you pulled off with
this
um thank you nowadays we are in such a
politically correct time
where everyone is work i found out this
new word there was using woke
oh i wasn't going to use that word is
that what work means
yeah i don't want to say what it does it
doesn't i think you've got to be work
to know how to use the word work yeah i
found that's the sad thing about work
is that you have to be worked to be work
and
obviously not work because i don't get
work i understand
i'm not engaging on this one at all the
thing about this is though
you you wrote a script that is uh it's
just everyone's politically correct
nowadays and i commend you
for this material taking on this
material and fox searchlight for making
it
uh was it tough to get the green light
on this thing there was no real pitching
process
for this so i didn't go to studios and
sort of say
hey this is my idea for a film it's
about this kid and growing up in world
war ii
it was i realized really early on that
it's a very hard film to pitch and i'm
coming from new zealand we're terrible
at pitching
so i didn't really bother and
after talking to my friends and saying
they said what are you up to now and
what are you writing
while i'm doing this thing it's about
this kid in world war ii and they were
i'm not interested and so that kind of
that made me realize oh no one really
wants to hear a pitch like this
so i'm going to write a script that's
that's really good and i'm going to let
that be the pitch
so i wrote the screenplay and i just
sent that around i said i'm not gonna
come and talk to you about it
you just read the script and if you like
it then we can talk and then search like
read it and they said let's talk and
they said and i had no interest in no
intention of playing hitler and
they said we want to make the film and
we only really want to do it if you
play hitler what's wrong with these
people i
love that story like uh one of the
things about this though
is that i think it's more important than
ever that every year there's something
about world war
ii that gets made to shine a light on
the atrocities that happened
and what that was all about because it
seems more relevant than ever
to be talking about this um can you sort
of talk about
that aspect of shining a light on this
dark period
well i don't know if you're aware
there's a little guardian article that
came out where they
released the um the results of a survey
which showed that 41
of americans and 66 of american
millennials um the devotee of auschwitz
so that was to me was that's a really
shocking stat and
you know when so when people go oh
there's another you know
why do we have to keep having these
world war two movies now why don't we
keep
hearing about world war ii we get it we
obviously don't get it because
stats like that exist and this is one
year ago
you know people don't know the name of
you know one of the most famous
concentration camps
[Music]
and what that means and yeah and and the
impact of that name
uh then we do need to keep making these
films and we do need to keep this
conversation going
and we can't get complacent and just
keep making the same style the same
tonal style of film it's just all it's
drama it's depressing we have to like
you know
everything's desaturated and browns and
grays and
we could also maybe crazy idea we could
also make something that's colorful and
bright and has
humor in and has like a real life to it
um and mixes humor and drama
and has an imaginary hitler character in
it just anything to keep people
talking about it and and to tell the
story again and again in in new and
inventive ways
oh absolutely um uh what
what was it like did you know this was
when you sat down to write the script
because i think the script's incredible
did you know the the tone early on of
what you were trying to do or did you
sort of figure it out in the writing
process
i knew the time really early on i knew
that i wasn't going to make a film that
was just
um completely irreverent and just you
know took the person didn't have any
like anything really to say or just made
jokes you know
i didn't want to make just a flat-out
comedy about world war two because
why would you and it's kind of
inappropriate
you know to brush over the atrocities
and you know the experiences of
millions people so so i wanted to do
something that
had heart and had meaning and had a
message and hopefully could enact some
sort of
change could bring about some sort of um
change in
you know in anyone and
so that was really the the key is like
you're trying to do a film like that and
um
and yeah trying to make a difference i i
always i think i did this when the last
time we spoke uh
i'm always curious about the editing
process because that's the final rewrite
when you stepped in the editing room
with all your footage what maybe
made you super happy what made you
nervous what were you feeling
when you started editing with every
single film i make
i'd say there's about three or four or
three months in the edit
where i think this is the last thing
anyone should watch
and i feel like
why would anyone want to watch this and
it's really because you're oversaturated
you've been living with the footage for
so long and you kind of you've reached
this
point of being numb to it and you have
to kind of you have to keep reminding
yourself
the audience has never seen this the
audience has never seen all the footage
they haven't seen all of the you know 22
takes of you trying to get this one
thing right they haven't seen any of
that and they don't care
they just want to see a good story and
that kind that's how i kind of bolster
myself and
pick myself up it's okay okay yeah i've
got to keep working and make a story
yeah and just concentrate on
on the story um but yeah the editing
process
is and then this particular film there
wasn't any particular
one thing that i found really hard it
was more
the tonal balance just trying to get
that right so i test my films all the
time with
audiences and i get feedback and say
what do you think of this
how were you bored here were you are we
overstimulated here
was it too funny here you know it wasn't
too sad here and then just finding your
balance and go okay well now
let's take the audience you know they've
been
there they've had the deep meaningful
moments you know they've been it's been
emotional
now we can slowly pick them up with some
lightness and get into a few jokes here
and then kind of ease them back into
this bit here and then and
it's really like just sort of massaging
the audience through the story and like
figuring out asking them are you okay
you know
where do you want to go now okay well
let's go over here and show you this
so that's essentially how i try
and make a maybe uh i have to stop there
and i'm just going to say
uh seriously congrats on the movie it's
one of the year's best and congrats on
winning the audience award of toronto
thanks brother